what is Sims easier everybody who hasn't
experiences it in different ways so I
also handful of people from around the
world about their experience so
somewhere in my brain the senses get
mixed together when I experience one I'm
also experiencing another that is
completely unrelated what do you mean I
color code numbers in my head so ever
since I was a child I was able to taste
work if I'm in physical pain I
experienced the pain in color and shape
sounds melodies and in fact sound tracks
also has a color to me so what sort of
associations would you make the number
three is blue number three is light blue
three is yellow number six is a flirty
woman four is green two is red 42 is
green red that's my favorite number
because I like the colors red and green
together but wait it gets weirder for
example I love Flashdance songs she's a
maniac is blue one for me but what a
feeling is yellow word people taste is
like meatballs in tomato sauce diamonds
as navy blue rectangles moving from
right to left the word English paste is
like a slice of lemon the sound of the
banjo taste is like Oreos crazy right
but a life without it hmm my life
without synesthesia I don't want to
imagine more empty this would be a lot
more blue world would be very flat and
not as colorful I would be bored